herr söder freue mich dass sie für uns
zeit gefunden haben sind hektische tage
und auch entscheidungs wichtige
entscheidungen die anstehen die grenzen
zu tschechien und österreich sollen
dicht gemacht werden wie soll das
konkret ablaufen nun die grenzen leben
nicht leicht gemacht aber es wird die
sicherheitsfrage deutlich erhöht
faktisch folgendes wir haben in bayern
in den letzten wochen eine sehr gute
entwicklung gehabt 90 prozent reduktion
der infektionszahlen wir waren mal auf
platz eins der inzidenz liegen jetzt auf
zwischen neun und zehn
also sind wir haben eine sehr sehr
positive entwicklung muss man sagen
nähern uns bald in 50
aber wir haben die problemlage an den
grenzen und insbesondere die hotspots
tirschenreuth oder wunsiedel
dort ist der eintrag aus tschechien auf
der nachbar seite ist er ist die zahl
sehr hoch tschechien beginnt die eigene
gebiete abzuriegeln und was jetzt das
eigentlich entscheiden ist wir haben
festgestellt dass bei den tschechischen
einträgen also den tests die wir schon
gemacht haben 70 prozent beispielsweise
in wunsiedel aus der mit der britischen
mutante versehenes und über 40 prozent
in tirschenreuth es heißt seine reale
herausforderung vor der wir stehen und
deswegen haben wir jetzt den bund
gebeten dies zu mutations gebiet zu
erklären
das gilt sowohl für tschechien als auch
für tirol wo die südafrikanische
variante verstärkt vorkommt und dann
muss jeder der einreist und es gibt
keine ausnahme er muss einen negativen
test vorliegen ist der unterschied zu
jetzt jetzt und das meer heißt nicht
dicht machen aber natürlich besser
kontrollieren und ich glaube das ist
auch absolut notwendig denn es geht hier
um sicherheit und schutz auch bei uns
und deswegen glaube ich muss man das
einfach tun sonst wird ja das alles was
die menschen hier an an entbehrungen auf
sich nehmen ständig konterkariert zumal
die mutations wären auch gefährliche
aggressiver sind und deswegen müssen wir
die zahlen senken und das geht nur mit
dieser vor sich aber es noch mal
deutlich zu sagen sie sagen die grenzen
werden nicht dichtgemacht die meldung
die ich heute gelesen habe waren genau
dieser walliser duktus dieser wortlaut
das heißt tschechen können nach wie vor
die grenze passieren jeder der möchte
oder nur pendler und österreicher genau
das gleiche
man muss einen negativen test vorliegen
wenn man den nicht vorlegen kann
dann gibt es keine 1 30 dann gibt es
eine zurückweisung
wenn man mal vergleicht mit letzten jahr
da war es ja noch strenger es war
übrigens auch ein teil des erfolges wenn
man es so sehen wir im frühjahr
slaughter und war tatsächlich der
unterschied auch zu den maßnahmen der
vergangenen wochen war tatsächlich das
damals die grenzen sogar komplett
geschlossen war nur für den warenverkehr
für mehr nicht übrigens auf der
österreichischen seite wird es auch sehr
streng kontrolliert also ich glaube wir
sind da wirklich jetzt klug beraten in
dieser phase in der wir sind wo wir zwar
einerseits sinkende zahlen haben einen
verbesserten verlauf auch fast 90
prozent bei uns auch umgekehrt die zahl
der toten zu rücken dass wir diesen
erfolg nicht gefährden
wir müssen die zahlen weiter senken
damit wir bei einer aufsteigenden
mutations komponente einfach auf der
sicheren seite stehen soweit man das
überhaupt sagen kann und deswegen ist es
gerade bei den hot spots in tschechien
und bei der vorsorge bei südtirol
beziehungsweise studium tirol wichtig
einfach auf der vorsichtigen seite zu
stehen lediglich gesteigerten wert
darauf dass das ding in südtirol
offiziell zumindest noch nicht
angekommen ist aber es hat ganz
persönliche gründe aber land sie wissen
dass südtirol leider südtirol ist leider
sie müssen wir sind ja bayern große fans
von südtirol aber das ja auch ein
beispiel südtirol war ja super unterwegs
der hat dann sehr schnell gelockert und
hat heute extrem holt sein also der
mechanismus der ist eigentlich immer
überall in europa in den letzten monaten
der gleiche gewesen und dafür wollen wir
uns halt ein stück weit auch schützen
beziehungsweise umgekehrt die motivation
und akzeptanz bei der eigenen
bevölkerung nicht schwächen indem wir
das heimlich in höhe des jahren habe es
auch sehen dass frau verlange sagt da
ist ja ein an dem grenzbereich ähnliches
dort wir müssen halt einfach zu vorsicht
ist die mutter der porzellankiste fragen
weil sie gerade angesprochen sind wie
wollen sie es machen in flensburg ist
die grenze nach dänemark zu also ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass wir
natürlich im grenzland das wort
grenzschließung überhaupt nicht gerne
hören und ich bin auch davon überzeugt
dass sich das virus an keinem schlagbaum
hält und in der tat können wir durch
infektionsketten nachverfolgung schon
auch sagen ja wir haben sicherlich eine
verbindung zu dänemark auch was die
mutation angeht aber ich bin davon
überzeugt dass wir ganz andere maßnahmen
brauchen und wir im grenzland wir haben
hier eine sonder
die menschen im grenzland können sich
frei nach dänemark bewegen wenn sie
einen test vorweisen
und ich will noch mal betonen 12.000
menschen bei uns in der region sind auf
ihren arbeitsplatz in dänemark
angewiesen also was ist das für eine
grenzschließung was sage ich den
menschen die dort ihr täglich brot
verdienen
ich glaube wir müssen uns eher beispiel
nehmen zum beispiel an der nationalen
test strategie des landes dänemark und
ich würde mich freuen wenn wir viel viel
lieber darüber diskutieren dass wir in
deutschland eine solche test strategie
auch einführen und darin investieren als
in diese diskussion nach grenchen denn
wenn sie es gerade ansprechen können sie
das einmal kurz in zwei sätzen reißen
dänische test strategie wie worin
unterscheidet die sich von der deutschen
ja dass die dänische regierung einfach
auch die test kapazitäten so zur
verfügung stellt wie sie gebraucht
werden und man kann auf der dänischen
seite vielfach an der autobahn einfach
raus warentest machen sich den beleg
holen der gebraucht wird und der wird
auch gefordert gerade für den menschen
die grenzpendler sind arbeiten diesseits
und jenseits der grenze
das findet man auf der deutschen seite
nicht und auf der deutschen seite findet
man private unternehmen ja das ist gut
dass wir die als partner haben aber ich
wünsche mir dass vielmehr tatsächlich im
rahmen der test strategie im übrigen ist
die deutsche -test strategie immer noch
so angelegt dass man erst symptome
aufweisen muss
sie ist nichts wenn tief angelegt sie
ist nachverfolgen angelegt und da
wünsche ich mir einen deutlichen
qualitätssprung ich glaube da geht mehr
ganz kurz bei herr söder wird unruhig
bilanz wenn ich nein ich will nur sagen
dass diese so genannte dänische
strategie schon lang eine bayerisches
bei uns ist tatsächlich anders verlangen
wir haben es von anfang an anders
gemacht
bei uns kann jeder mann test machen
völlig umsonst wir haben überall
kommunale testzentren wir haben an der
grenze übrigens direkt noch einmal auch
für die pendler sogar die möglichkeit
fertig für die pendler die aus
tschechien waren ein test umsonst zu
machen sonst wüssten wir unter uns
gesagt gar nicht dass wir so eine hohe
moderation an weil wir diese tests
stattgefunden haben auch alles
sequenziert haben und damit wissen die
auch die zahl und daraus folgt auch
natürlich das bewusstsein dass wir mit
dem mond testen ein reales
infektionsgeschehen es haben dass sich
abbildet und genau daraus folgt dann die
frage eben ein negativer test bei
einreise sicher dass die zahlen sind
einfach zu hoch ab einer bestimmten höhe
springen die zahlen und sind nicht mehr
kontrollierbar und das ist es einfach
wichtig da das safe zu sein und diese
maßnahmen zu machen die anderen dinge
die wir bei uns machen
die finden ja ohnehin staat ich wurde ja
immer dafür kritisiert dass wir zu viel
testen aber genau das gegenteil ist das
jetzt tun das erst mal nicht geklappt
hat ja alles hat auch damit zu tun dass
es noch nicht einmal aber das ist ja
nicht hingegen ja ja einmal herr lanz
und das heißt praktisch oder im
dreivierteljahr ich weiß und das ist wie
wenn fehler passieren das ist mir völlig
recht ja hat uns auch geärgert aber die
strategie war natürlich absolut richtig
und ich glaube trotzdem fressen ist ein
heikler politischer moment herr söder
wir haben in den vergangenen tagen viel
über impfstoff beschaffung gesprochen es
wurde immer wieder das böse wort
international ist raus geholte leute die
frage gestellt haben
wie kann es eigentlich sein dass ein
impfstoff der in deutschland entwickelt
wurde dann einfach plötzlich gar nicht
zur verfügung steht zumindest nicht
rechtzeitig würde uns jetzt zum beispiel
auch wirklich sehr sehr helfen
und plötzlich sind wir an dem punkt dass
wir tatsächlich diesen europäischen
gedanken ad absurdum führen wir ziehen
grenzt im grunde wieder hoch sie sagen
die grenze bleibt zwar offen aber
faktisch ist das gefühl dass entsteht
und auch die die idee die die das ganze
mühselige dass damit auch verbunden ist
die frage wie lange müssen leute in
quarantäne plötzlich haben wir das
mitten in europa und wir sind das kern
land mit in europa österreich ist das
durchzugs land in europa das heißt wir
haben keine offenen grenzen wir können
uns darauf einigen welche nicht die
bundeskanzlerin hat bei einem der
letzten europäischen räte das genau
angesprochen sagt gesagt für die
freizügigkeit für die freiheit und für
das miteinander europa ist dann aber
auch natürlich dass wir wenn wir die
freiheit haben auch die verpflichtung
haben gemeinsam maßnahmen zu ergreifen
und der bund hat ja heute entschieden
die beiden bereiche tschechien und tirol
zur mutations gebeten zu machen warum
weil er auf der tschechischen seite
nicht ganz sicher ist wie die maßnahmen
angewendet werden und wenn sie nach
tirol schauen nicht südtirol
dann stellen sie fest dass wien auf der
einen seite für österreich extrem öffnet
in tirol aber einschneidende maßnahmen
machen will und die tiroler regierung
hat die maßnahmen aus wien kommentiert
mit dem wort das sei ein rückseite der
bundesregierung ein nicht sehr
konstruktive antwort darauf so dass auch
hier der bund zum einem völlig zu recht
sagt wir wir machen da die sicherheit
und wir führen dann der grenzkontrollen
ein es in stationären grenzkontrollen
mit der möglichkeit wenn jemand eben
einreisenden mit negativen test okay
dann ist es sicher aber wenn er keinen
test vorliegen kann dann ist nämlich
sicherheit an oberster stelle
das ist schon sehr sinnvoll und
entspricht übrigens auch im
freiheitlichen europa der der der der
herr der den rückstau aus wien da gehört
hat das war glaube ich franz völker der
seilbahn beauftragte es auch ganz
interessant in tirol führen viele wege
am ende immer zur seilbahn gesellschaft
muss man verstehen wir werden gleich
noch zu corinna milborn nach wien
schalten die erzählt da sind teilweise
wieder zustände wie in der piefke sage
damals gesagt dass wenn wir gleich hören
nur trotzdem die frage herr söder sie
haben gerade gesagt in österreich wird
aufgemacht inzidenz in österreich
deutlich über 100 was wenn diese
nächsten wochen in österreich in eine
völlig falsche richtung laufen und und
sie dann vor der frage stehen wann mache
ich diesen grenzverkehr wieder wirklich
auf oder nicht wie lange wollen sie das
durchhalten im zweifel und wie wollen
sie jemals auf die 35 kommen die ja seit
gestern plötzlich im raum steht sie
haben gerade die zahlen genannt
wunsiedel 304 der tirschenreuth 392 das
ist in der oberpfalz an der
tschechischen grenze hof 285 wie wollen
sie da jemals landesweit auf 35 kommen
ja das ist schon sehr möglich denn sie
dürfen nicht vergessen landesweit haben
wir heute incidents die unter dem
bundesdurchschnitt liegt wir liegen auf
platz neun
von allen bundesländern übrigens gar
nicht weit entfernt von schleswig
holstein selbst des landes ja ich sag
das übrigens nicht als eine art
wettbewerb sondern einfach man kann
innerhalb kürzester zeit obwohl man auf
der sicheren seite war schnell zum
hotspot werden das in entwicklung und
die gehen ganz schnell in kleinen
landkreisen übrigens ist es so dass es
über tirschenreuth steigt die inzidenz
sehr hoch an schauen sie im vergleich
münchen ist die millionenstadt in
deutschland mit dem besten incidents
wert was von der einwohnerzahl natürlich
eine ganz andere
so also wir sind liegen da gut und die
35 also nach wenn alles so bliebe wie
jetzt wenn alles so bliebe jetzt das
heißt wenn die mutation nicht stark zum
tragen kommt sagen die experten unseres
landesamtes für gesundheit auf der basis
der daten auch das lka dass wir ende
ende februar vielleicht unter die 50
sind und mitte märz sogar unter den 35
insgesamt aber das entscheidende punkt
wenn wir den weg so vorsichtig
fortsetzen österreich macht mir deswegen
gedanken ich werde sehen unbedingt
kritisieren im ersten das entscheidet
sich wie ein selbst müsst euch macht ein
ständiges hin und her ein stop and go
ein vornehm zurück es ist ja nicht der
zweite lok dann in der wir uns in der
phase befinden sondern bereits der
dritte und mein gefühl ist es so eine
art welle sein in dem das macht auf und
zu ich glaube dass die strategie das
problem dass die schäden nicht nur
gesundheitlich auch wirtschaftlich
deutlich größer sind wir überhaupt keine
planbarkeit keine echte perspektive da
ist und der wahrheit ist einfach auch
das ist auf dauer die akzeptanz der
bevölkerung völlig schlecht denn eins
muss man schon sagen ich bin den
menschen in bayern aber in deutschland
sowieso überall unglaublich dankbar wie
diszipliniert die bürgerinnen bürger bei
uns dies auch machen und bei allen
nebenwirkungen und schäden und
schwierigkeiten ist unbestritten
wirtschaftlich seelisch das ist ja alles
da das kann man nicht wegdiskutieren
wenn wir gleich am ende haben wir das
bislang finde ich jetzt auch in der
zweiten welle viel besser durchgestanden
als viele andere länder
und ich möchte dass es so bleibt und um
macht und österreich sorge und deswegen
beachten wir das sehr genau der bund hat
und somit seine entscheidung finde ich
sehr geholfen bin da sehr dankbar der
bundeskanzlerin aber auch der
bundesinnenminister
ich bin ich also teile vieles von dem
was sie sagen herr söder ich glaube aber
wir sollten uns darauf verständigen dass
wir mit dem mit dem eigenlob in sachen
wir machen das viel besser als viele
viele andere länder mittlerweile
zurückhalten sollten wir haben
mittlerweile todeszahlen die teilweise
die sagen der usa und anderer auf die
region mit dem finger gezeigt haben
deutlich übersteigen
also ich glaube wir sind auch in einem
ganz krisenhaften punkt und diese 35 zum
beispiel ist psychologisch auch wichtig
also ich hab gestern gesagt die ganze
zeit hängt so zu sagen dass das hähnchen
bei 50 plötzlich hängt ist bei 35 um die
frage
was dann bei 35 passiert ist übrigens
auch nicht eindeutig geklärt dann
gestern mit herrn changer dem dem
bürgermeister aus hamburg sehr intensiv
darüber gesprochen
er sagte das ist eine kann regelung ich
kann bei 35 etwas aufmachen
das ist überhaupt nicht mit einer
konsequenz einer pflicht sozusagen
verbunden dinge aufzumachen und dann
kommt die frage wenn das länder weit
landesweit geregelt ist sie in bayern
beispielsweise sie ist gerade im
bayerischen durchschnitt erwähnt aber
sie haben immer noch wurden siegel bei
304 was wenn sie im schnitt irgendwann
mal bei 24 angekommen sind als beispiel
habe aber nach wie vor in tirschenreuth
ihre 200 oder was auch immer dürften die
dann aufmachen oder bleiben die zu das
ist doch die große entscheidende frage
was heißt das für die leute vor ort was
machen sie dann
er habe völlig recht es ist eine ganz
entscheidende frage deswegen gab es auch
gestern so eine debatte darüber ob nicht
eine zahl am besten bundesweit zunächst
mal gelten sollte um auch eine art
einkaufstourismus zu verhindern weil
sein wenn man sieht ist die sendung aus
hamburg wenn ich zwischen hamburg sagen
wir und der im schleswig holstein oder
niedersachsen
denn ein großes einzugsbereich
einzugsgebiet ist es sehr schwierig wir
haben ja wenn sie zum beispiel auch auch
der hof nehmen oder wunsiedel deshalb
mit einer tschechien als ganzes sondern
eben auch thüringen und sachsen in der
nähe so dass man da auch tatsächlich die
verbindungen spürt die sind aber wir
haben es ja gestern folgendes genau das
gab gestern ja den wunsch von einigen
ganz sehr schnell alles auf zu machen da
fand ich haben uns auf einen guten
kompromiss geeinigt stück für stück hat
den kanzeln auch sehr gebremst und ist
eine richtige form finde ich auch
gebracht dass zweites wir sagen jetzt
dann in der nächsten woche das besser
abzuschätzen ob die weiterentwicklung
der mutation schauen wir wie die gesamt
incidents ist geht es weiter runter
möglichst niedrig ab 35 besteht dann die
perspektive für den handel müssen uns in
der tat und so genau ist es noch nicht
formuliert worden
dann überlegen welche möglichkeiten
gehen natürlich ist für hot spots das
war übrigens bereits vorher so bei uns
wir hatten eine krone ampel die diese
zahlen übrigens schon hatte er ganz so
wir hatten die zahlen 100 beispielsweise
für hot spot wir hatten die 250 als
orientierung sozusagen für die
gesundheitsämter und 35 was unter 35 war
wacker sie grünes licht
der einteilung weil das war auch der
grund warum ein bisschen skeptisch waren
bei so 89 stufen plänen verstehen tut
die nämlich keiner merkt es ja auch so
ein punkt ist die menschen ist verstehen
müssen wenn sie acht neun stufen kann
kein mensch sich merken sind drei so
eine ampel geht und wenn man die 35
erreicht dann glaube ich insgesamt wenn
man die 35 insgesamt liegt man gut bei
uns was aber schon froh wenn dann ein
hotspot war in der moritzburg kann das
dann nicht stattfinden deswegen noch mal
die frage herr söder
schließen sie die dann ein spiegeln sie
hof dann ab tirschenreuth oder auch
wunsiedel zum beispiel was machen sie
dann lassen sie die nicht nach
regensburg fahren beispielsweise ist das
machen sie erinnern sie sich an
berchtesgaden berchtesgaden war doch am
anfang sehr stark betroffen
im herbst werden sich vielleicht noch im
oktober noch damals auch ein sehr
starker eintrag aus österreich damals
und dann haben wir genau diese maßnahmen
gemacht haben dass schulen geschlossen
wir haben dort geschäfte geschlossen und
es ging sehr schnell sehr stark runter
auch theoretisch könnte dann hätte
jemand aus berchtesgaden nach münchen
fahren können haben sie völlig recht
es hat sich aber relativ gut organisiert
deswegen ist das an der stelle machbar
und auch kontrollierbar wenn es
insgesamt niedriges problem ist immer
dann wenn es in der breite springt dann
haben wir dieses berühmte diffuse
geschehen das ist ja bis heute wissen
sie eine der spannenden fragen wir haben
bei uns alle experten der verkauf
nationaler ebene wo ist denn wirklich
ansteckung weil wir hören ja immer
wieder das argument also da habe ich
eine idee konzept und dann kann nichts
passieren und eigentlich kann nirgendwo
was passieren fakt ist einfachen diffus
heißt es ist breit und es geht nur die
summe der maßnahmen von geschäften von
schulen von kontakten bei uns war ja
auch die ausgangssperre lange ein sehr
wirksames instrument ähnlich wie in
baden wird und das wird jetzt
zurückgefahren weil wir besser liegen
aber in hotspots funktioniert es immer
noch und dabei muss es auch noch einmal
ganz kurz herr söder auf die
widersprüchlichkeit jeder auch drin
steckt ist es richtig dass sie ab einer
inzidenz unter 100 trotzdem dann die
grundschulen wieder aufmachen und
schulen überhaupt während nur die
grundschulen in der tat jetzt haben wir
ja für vereinbart wechsel unterricht
aber nur wechsel unterricht
das heißt sehr sehr kleine gruppen in
eine woche die eine hälfte an der woche
die andere hälfte beobachten ist auch
sehr genau welche auswirkung hat nur die
kleinsten bei durch die schäden am
größten sind und deswegen machen wir das
ganz langsam ab dem 25
die haben da auch die abwägung zu
treffen gehabt bei den weiterführenden
schulen distanz und durch glaubt auch
sehr sehr gut ist bleibt auch so hat
sich übrigens auch bewährt mittlerweile
auch bei eltern lehrern und schülern
ebenfalls für die nächste zeit und bei
den kleinen ist es halt einfach so dass
der distanz unterricht nicht die
entsprechende adäquate form der
betreuung eingang
aber anstatt in vollen präsenzunterricht
zu machen wie manche setzen wir da auf
den vorsichtigen weg wechsel und aber
grundschüler dürfen dann ohne maske im
unterricht sitzen bei incidents knapp
unter 100 nein wir haben nein nein wir
haben immer masken pflicht ich habe
damals schon kritisiert weil wir masken
pflicht auch in der grundschule
ja ja natürlich es geht auch ist kein
problem ja ich weiß genau okay das
wollte ich noch mal kurz geklärt haben
sie sagten gerade wir haben es immer wir
haben es immer gemacht hatten damals
auch großen ärger bekommen am anfang
es ist immer so bei vielen der maßnahme
die die man trifft am anfang ist es
immer so muss ich ehrlich sagen gibt es
immer einen großen aufschrei die
maßnahmen ergebnis das geht nicht am
ende sind die menschen immer unglaublich
gewöhnen sich nicht nur schnell dran von
die schüler und schüler muss ich sagen
das ist immer ganz großartige junge
menschen die viele der maßnahmen wobei
älteren häufig klagen dann sehr auch
spielerisch und gut umsetzt lasst uns
doch mal anfragen sie haben gestern
interessanten satz gesagt nach der
konferenz die lage ist zwar besser aber
die stimmung im land ist deutlich
schwieriger geworden thailands jetzt bei
uns 19 jahre alt deren ganz guten
überblick hat darüber wie es sozusagen
um das um das psychische befinden auch
genau dieser generation ist der einen
krisen chetwie werden gleich ausführlich
darüber sprechen kann
ins leben gerufen hat ich habe nur eine
sehr beeindruckende zahl im kopf ich
glaube am anfang waren es um die 2000
kinder jugendliche die sich da gemeldet
haben pro tag also in der ersten welle
mittlerweile sind wir bei knapp 15.000
also wir haben insgesamt bisher über
15.000 beratungen durchgeführt also das
jetzt nicht täglich
unser angebot wird natürlich auch immer
bekannter das merken wir natürlich aber
es aber ein problem mit offensichtlich
auch direkter gerne auch also ich würde
aber trotzdem aufpassen
wir reden natürlich viel darüber die
psychische gesundheit der kinder und
jugendlichen verschärft sich natürlich
total durch so ein lockdown aber auf der
anderen seite sollten wir auch nicht
vergessen dass die zahlen vorher auch
nicht super sind und wir sollten jetzt
auf keinen fall denken der lok dann ist
vorbei jetzt ist alles wieder gut jetzt
geht es den jugendlichen wieder gut
einerseits gibt es sehr viele
langfristige fälle
andererseits ist auch schon so die
psychische gesundheit ein großes problem
also der bundespsychotherapeutenkammer
spricht davon dass 18 prozent der kinder
und jugendlichen 2009/10 psychische
belastungen haben sind wir für
dreieinhalb millionen unter 25-jährigen
sind unglaubliche zahlen und ich glaube
dass da dieser lockt dann aber auch
einen guten blick auf dieses problem
werfen kann aber und genau und hat das
visum katalysator wie so ein brennglas
so genau
die studie in hamburg rausgekommen von
der uniklinik eppendorf die gesagt haben
dass jedes dritte kind psychisch
belastet ist momentan an
und das sehen wir natürlich bei uns
total was hören sie aus bayern
beispielsweise weil wir gerade mit
markus söder sprechen ja also wir sehen
natürlich dass es bundesweit überall
probleme gibt wir können nicht genau
sagen hier ist es in dem bundesland
jetzt besonders stark und ich möchte
jetzt auch nicht mit dem finger auf
irgendjemanden zeigen
ich glaube dass einfach ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches problem ist und
ich glaube es löst man nicht dadurch
dass man irgendwie sagt ja hier in dem
bundesland geht es noch ein bisschen
besser und in dem ein bisschen
schlechter sondern ich glaube wir müssen
uns in ganz deutschland gedanken machen
wie wir das problem angehen
fakt dass auch deswegen noch einmal
diese diese zahl 35 gerard krause hier
sitzt der sagt zitiere die todesfälle
die wir haben
die todesfälle die sie auch angesprochen
haben und die am ende auch dazu führen
dass wir diese harten maßnahmen haben
dass wir mittlerweile runter sind auf
dieser zahl auf 35 die nicht einfach zu
erreichen ist gérard krause sagt
todesfälle finden ja in einer art
mikrokosmos stadt nämlich in alten und
pflegeheimen in denen der lockdown
persia erstmal gar nicht will
was heißt das natürlich gibt es auch
woanders todesfälle na ja ich möchte
jetzt nicht so absolut aber zum großen
teil das sind aber die weit überwiegende
zahl der todesopfer findet halt bei den
menschen statt die über 80 sind über 75
sind und insbesondere in den alten und
pflegeheimen warum dort weil dort die
menschen besonders schwach sind und weil
sie in eine umgebung leben wo eine
übertragung also wir reden da von
nosokomialen übertragung also
übertragung in der einrichtung besonders
leicht passieren kann dh doppeltes
risiko so zu sagen man ist altmann hat
pflegebedürftigkeit drei jahre sogar und
man lebt in einer einrichtung wo andere
menschen mit hohem risiko sind und das
ist ja ein bekanntes phänomen das ist
jetzt nichts was uns hätte überraschen
müssen
und leider hat sich gezeigt dass und das
war auch eigentlich absehbar dass die
diese ganzen kontakt reduzierende
maßnahmen der gesamtgesellschaft
insbesondere in der jüngeren generation
sich diesbezüglich kaum auswirken genau
das heißt wir machen unglaublich viele
dinge aber haben quasi kein effekt na ja
sie haben effekt für die senkung der
fallzahlen sie haben infekt bei der bei
der anderen seite fälle bei der jüngeren
generation aber tatsächlich bei der
prävention der todesfälle der schweren
verläufe haben sie ein vergleichsweise
geringen effekt gehabt weil und das ist
meine sorge bei dieser angelegenheit wie
auch jetzt in dieser talkshow wir
diskutieren in der ganzen gesellschaft
unglaublich viel unglaublich intensiv
für diese allgemeinen kontakt
reduzierende maßnahmen da investieren
wir unsere ganze energie und
aufmerksamkeit rhein und den bereich wie
schützen wir die menschen die am meisten
beschützt werden müssen
das überlassen wir letztendlich den
krankenhäusern den geriatrie den
pflegekräften in pflegeeinrichtungen den
mobilen pflegediensten fast allein und
haben das in unserer gesellschaft
eigentlich erst relativ spät zum thema
gemacht auch der aktuellste bericht von
gestern äußert sich zu dem thema fast
gar nicht genau
wenn man es vergleicht das dann also ein
ganzer absatz ein ganzer punkt den
friseur betrieben gewidmet wird dann
finde ich da ein gewisses
ungleichgewicht das ist genau der punkt
herr söder also die sache mit den
friseuren überhaupt nichts gegen
friseure aber herr kraus hatten punkt
wenn er sagt über das worum es
eigentlich geht und was von anfang an
das erklärte ziel der pandemie war
nämlich wirklich die alten in der
gesellschaft zu schützen weil die die
verletzlichsten sind was dieses virus
angeht was koch 2 angeht findet sich in
diesem ganzen papier im grunde kaum was
aber vier zeilen über friseure ist dass
ernsthaft ein verhältnis von dem sie
sagen würden so ist das in ordnung wenn
sie die so zusammenstellen entsteht der
eindruck ist aber nicht fair insofern
weil wir nie der mpk also in jeder
dieser konferenzen der letzten monate
uns primär genau auch im system erhalten
und pflegeheime gekümmert haben
deswegen ist es ja auch so dass in der
impfstrategie dort alles geimpft wird
was geht also verimpft wird an impfstoff
essen haben ja die priorität auch gesetz
der woanders dann noch nicht ausreichend
zur verfügung steht auch die zweit
impfungen schon mit etwas glück werden
wir gerade in den nächsten wochen alle
alten und pflegeheime in deutschland so
hoffen wir durch geimpft haben was
übrigens dann so wichtig ist für die
weitere entwicklung der ganzen maßnahmen
in der pandemie weil dann in der tat die
das risiko der mortalität also der der
sterbenden der toten deutlich reduziert
werden kann
dort ist absolute priorität mit tests
pflichten mit personaleinsatz die
bundeswehr es da tätig um zu
unterstützen
test zu machen es gibt es pflicht sowohl
für die mitarbeiter zweimal zum teil
dreimal die woche wurde das mittlerweile
also das thema ist tatsächlich mehr als
auf dem schirm es wäre jetzt ungerecht
gegenüber den gesamten bundesländern
übrigens auch den kommunen die die
eigentliche heimaufsicht haben dass sie
das nicht tun werden ist der eine teil
der andere teil ist aber und das ist
gestern schon auch wichtig du musst auf
der einen seite den restriktiven teil
sehen du bist in sicherheits teil sehen
du musst die vorsicht definieren aber du
musst auch die perspektive sehen wir
haben keine echten planbarkeit mit cola
oder schwer das wissen wir alle
es kann sich über tage hinweg völlig für
das macht die menschen auch mürbe ist
auch der teil der viele stress neigen
auf uns ja alle miteinander würde auch
mal gerne in der sendung mit ihnen etwas
anderes reden als nur über kochen aber
es ist unsere aufgabe sich dem zu
stellen und geht es los dann stellen wir
halten es fest das ist keine mode
natürlich es ist aber keine mode frage
jetzt wenn ich das so sagen da für sie
und mich ist es eine frage besser oder
schlechter aus mag sein aber es gibt
viele menschen für die ist das auch eine
frage der hygiene
viele ältere die auch zu hause leben
können das allein schwer brauchen es
gibt auch viele menschen für dies ist
ein teil
da mag man schmunzeln drüber ich sehe
das schon ein teil auch der eigenen
würde und der körperhygiene und das ist
ein kleiner punkt wo wir sagen in der
entwicklung der eröffnungs schritte
dass das durchaus sinnvolles wir haben
eine andere bereiche auch medizinische
fußpflege und ähnliches mehr so da es
war ein punkt im team haben wir übrigens
auch nicht lang geredet sondern
hauptteil über den wir geredet haben ist
die dauerhafte fragen die dauerhafte
frage wie entwickelt sich die motivation
wie kann man das einschätzen und aus der
einschätzung nach außen dann lieber
vorsichtige schritte gehen um dort
keinen fehler zu
trotzdem es geht es geht natürlich auch
in dieser krise immer um kommunikation
vor allen dingen und ich sag mal so hat
es wenn sie sagen da geht es um würde
ich fand das einfach an sehr hohen griff
ins regal wenn man beim friseur dann
über würde spricht also was was wirklich
existenzielle ist für jeden menschen
einfach auspackt frag sie an dem punkt
ganz offen
wenn der spiels wort ladenbesitzer sein
laden über monate nicht mehr aufmachen
kann weil er angeblich viel gefährlicher
ist als der friseurladen neben ihm hat
das dann nicht auch was mit würde zu tun
wenn der nicht einfach irgendwann mal
seine arbeit seiner tätigkeit mal wieder
nachgehen kann
von deren bis heute keiner mal wirklich
nachvollziehbar erklären kann was an ihm
eigentlich so mörderisch ist während
daneben beim edeka der einkauf läuft wie
immer
das kann keiner erklären weil sie ohne
wirklichen und erklärte es zum einmal
gibt es ja die möglichkeit von dem so
genannten click & collect das heißt
bestellen abholen geht das heißt das
nicht so dass es gar nicht stattfindet
zweitens wir haben das thema mobilität
in den städten es ist nicht das geschäft
die herausforderung sondern die menge
werden immer und auch alle großen
experten haben uns dass er gesagt
leopoldina zwei dinge müssen reduziert
worden
kontakte und mobilität und das spiel die
innenstadt szenarien natürlich eine ganz
entscheidende rolle
die supermärkte sollen im wesentlichen
den alltäglichen lebens bedarf decken
man muss ihr essen haben man muss die
notwendigen bereichen wir haben
apotheken natürlich geöffnet auch
bestimmte bereiche drogerie wo es auch
um das ganze geht wenn sie eine
zahnbürste brauchen wenn sie sich der
normale hygiene pflegen
herr menschen müssen ihr leben auch
unter diesen schwierigen bedingungen
wirklich führen können und wir haben zum
beispiel auch physiotherapeuten
medizinische anwendungen werden
zugelassen
wie gesagt die medizinische fußpflege
und für viele menschen auch übrigens im
alter spielt der flüsse eine zentrale
rolle deswegen würde ich das ehrlich
gesagt nicht so lapidar etwas lächerlich
sagen nein sondern das haben uns
wirklich lange überlegt und ist auch
kein hohes regal
man muss das nicht überhöhen dieses
thema aber man sollte es ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht geringschätzig behandelt ist
jedenfalls hat meine überzeugung und
deswegen glaube ich ist es vertretbar
bis zu entscheiden und auch zu machen es
ist nicht das wichtigste thema aber für
viele menschen ist es wichtig und ein
ganz kleiner kleines signal und auch ein
hoffnungsschimmer